there are a lot of people who would have
us believe that kind of technology is
going to solve these problems you know
we don't really need to get together
with other people actually in often in
organizations you don't really need to
go to conferences or meet other people
you can just
phone them or you can do it now
virtually and i think there's some truth
that you can do some of those things
um but last night i was in toronto and i
went to a conference a
concert of some music from joni mitchell
and
leonard cohen and and i thought you know
you could get the cd would it be the
same
no will it ever be the same no will ever
can you have any technology which is
which if you like get captures what it
is to be human no
so actually you know the the answer is
not to move away from society and say
well
really we can strip out the bits that we
want and turn them into technology we
can't
and i think that's true for if you like
people who are developing policy and
practices
but also for us as individuals i think i
i
i
think technology is incredibly useful to
the extent that it facilitates social
processes
but if it's an excuse not to have those
social processes then i think by and
large it's damaging